so welcome everyone i'm delighted to
introduce you to jason picard who is the
founding assistant professor of
vietnamese history and culture
at vin university in hanoi vietnam
in addition to hosting an m.a from
cornell
and a phd in history from berkeley
jason has lived and worked for extended
periods in vietnam and is quite possibly
more familiar with the vietnamese
archives and the currents and trends of
vietnamese history and historiography
than any other scholar working today no
matter the place
i could say this based on experience
literally every time i have a question
about vietnamese history and i must
apologize to jason for this because he
must think i sometimes whenever i have a
question i just reach out to him for an
answer but especially every time i have
a question about vietnamese history
especially 20th century political
intellectual or social history jason
always has the answer
and when i say has the answer these
aren't just off-the-cuff speculative
answers the kind of thing that we all do
when we're talking about academic ideas
but they're always grounded fact-filled
evidence-based answers that demonstrate
an intimate knowledge of literatures in
vietnamese and in english in french as
well as source materials from the
vietnamese archives alternative archives
conversations he's had on the street
people he knows other scholars that he
can direct you to
i mean this is serious understanding and
deep knowledge of vietnamese history
um it's a real pleasure to have known
jason for for many years since he was
doing his m.a at cornell and it's been a
real inspiration to to just learn with
him on this journey into vietnam studies
he's the author of some truly important
works including fertile lands await the
promise and pitfalls of directed
resettlement 1954-1958
also renegades the story of south
vietnam's first national opposition
newspaper 1955 through 1958 both of
those are in the journal of vietnamese
studies i also encourage you to really
mine all of jason's writing some of his
book reviews will actually end up as
historiographical essays in their own
right
and also his m.a thesis and phd
dissertation as well really remarkable
works of scholarship
jason is currently completing a book
manuscript entitled fragmented loyalties
how vietnam's great migration
destabilized a nation and altered a war
which examines the impact of one of the
most crucial events of the vietnam's
20th century the migration of 1954
through 1955.
but please join me in welcoming jason uh
for today's talk vietnam's machiavelli
les deux
and his quest to shape the communist
party of vietnam jason
eric thank you so so much that was quite
a quite a welcome um i now feel almost
like
i should just field questions after that
um
so it's a real pleasure to be here
despite the late late hour in in vietnam
i recognize some people out there
uh ivan it's great to to see you it's
been a very very long time um and
there is a lot of material that i have
to cover and i'm obviously not going to
cover it all this i just wanted to start
by
um
discussing just briefly
how i came to this topic about uh
about six years ago i i had an
opportunity after i had finished
my dissertation to read
a book called uh the winning side ben
tank walk in vietnamese
and i was struck by the character tall i
think most of you will know the name
later call from the paris peace
conference with henry kissinger
uh paul was
kissinger's arch nemesis there some of
you may also know his name
as the lone soul who refused the nobel
peace prize back in 1973
but by and large in the west that's
about all that we know about him
recently some scholars have written um
more about this have delved in a bit
more about his role in the
in vietnam
his role in the communist party
but by and large he isn't he's an enigma
and
as i read this book
as i said six or so years ago
it struck me
the role that he had
as a seminal figure in the party was
remarkable and yet very few people are
aware of it
um and the the reason i say this the
seminal role
is because as you guys will see
his role was as the head for about 35
plus years the head
of the
central organization of the communist
party of vietnam
and some of you may be familiar with old
soviet history
with chinese history
the central organization of the
communist party was in all of these
countries
it was uh in charge of what's known as
the nomenclatura the nomenclature was
basically the list of names
it was the list of all of the
party officials with all all members so
we're talking in the case of vietnam
millions of members
and this central organization commission
was in charge of employment moving
people around
uh assigning people to jobs
this
might seem like a mundane task but it
also meant that later tau as the chief
of this organization was also holding
the
holding the levers of power
and as i thought about it more and more
i realized my goodness i know next to
nothing about how power actually
functions in the vietnamese in the
vietnamese party
um we've had in recent years we've had
some wonderful books um i think many of
you may be familiar with bill's book
on
ideology within the party which it's a
brilliant book i would recommend it to
anyone and everyone uh alec holcomb
recently published his his book with um
uh with hawaii again a brilliant book
and i would recommend it to everyone
and still i i'm still left all these
many years later many of you will
recognize david maher his book 19
1945 quest for power
um
i am still to this day left with the
question of how does
how does power exist within the
communist party
what role do
do things like relationships play
and this is something that is really
over the last few years has really
really dated me um and so about a year
or so ago i just started to play around
with latex hall i started collecting
uh some memoirs that i had found
there's some very famous ones by ben
um and uh several other
several other people
here
and john dayton
some of you may be familiar with them if
not not a big deal at any rate i just
got so
wrapped up in this um i kind of pushed
aside the other work i should be doing
and i just decided i'm going to start
delving into later paul who he was
what
what made him tick it was basically what
i wanted to know
and as i came to learn more about the
power the the levers of power that he
did hold
um as the chief of this
central organization commission
i realized
the kind of power that he wielded was
in so many ways enough that he was
shaping
up the party and the direction it would
cover even up to today which i'll
discuss at the very end i won't have a
very much time but i'd like to
conclude with a little discussion
um about his role in shaping
renovation in 1986. okay so that's just
kind of how i got to later call um so at
any rate
i hope this is working there we go
so as i said all of you probably
recognize this this is this is a very
famous image of later paul standing next
to henry kissinger in 1972-73
with the signature with the signing of
the paris peace accords
um
obviously he's quite famous for this
something else many of you may be
familiar with is the works of zumtuh
zunkuhong is a a vietnamese novelist
writer she today she lives
in paris
no longer welcome in vietnam
sadly
but she's written
many books about uh about vietnam
obviously but
in particular um examining the communist
party and one of her more recent books
the zenith
in vietnamese examines the party and her
description of the communist party at
the elite levels at the very top
is
one of that is extremely bleak
but the reason i have this image of the
zenith and the reason i think it's so
important that i mention this
is that her depiction of leytaw is of
particular interest here
in this book later paul is
his we
she doesn't use the name later called
she uses the name sal
now sao was actually
is actually the later paul's nickname uh
within the party uh einsal meaning
brother number six
uh so in this book there is a figure sao
six who is in charge of the uh
uh essential organization commission
now what makes her depiction of this so
remarkable is that she reveals something
that is whispered within vietnam which
is that ledoc did indeed try to have
uh ho chi minh murdered now there's no
evidence for this it's just something
that sometimes whispers
uh there is no evidence as i said for
this but nonetheless it's there in this
novel
but i think for those people who are
vietnamese and who've read it it's
stunning number one but number two
the description she gives which is that
the this man sal
orders the lights on zulem airfield uh
shut off in the middle of the night as
ho chi minh's flight is arriving i
cannot remember from where but arriving
from somewhere uh trying to touch down
the lights are turned off fortunately in
this novel uh uh the pilot who's uh
who's flying the plane
is a seasoned one and he is able to land
the plane without trouble
uh
so the reason i'm mentioning this is
there is a host of literature um we can
talk about these
kind of unofficial histories
uh novels short stories and memoirs
that depict uh that depict later tall as
a
a brilliant organizer
a man who played a a very central role
in the communist party for decades
but who is ruthless and brutal and
thought nothing but of himself
then there are the histories that the
official histories um the official
histories are
depict a very different figure yes he's
a um you know he's a strong figure
brilliant organizer but they'll depict
things
they depict ideas of this very resilient
revolutionary that's one quote a
brilliant organizer and i'd love to read
you a a description of later paul on the
100th anniversary of his birth this is
in 2011
um in the
communist review
of vietnam
they wrote comrade leyton was a tireless
revolutionary
one of ho chi minh's best students he
was among the most important cadre of
the august revolution
and a leading revolutionary in the wars
against the french and americans in
particular he devoted his revolutionary
life to building the party's
organization apparatus
he's described as this brilliant
negotiator the man who defeated who out
who out negotiated
henry kissinger
a man who survived the prisons of um
sungla bon dao and hua bing
uh so these are kind of the depictions
of him as this
is this
luminary of the communist party this
great figure who would not count to the
french who would never cow to the
americans
and who led the way um in terms of organ
organizing uh the communist party
uh
so we have this kind of dichotomy and of
course in the west yes we know about him
as this great figure at uh at uh in
paris
but uh beyond that there's not really
that much more known about him so anyway
what i really wanted to do today we have
all of this all this stuff out there
um
differing ideas about who later paul was
and they all kind of collect little bits
of details here and there they put they
kind of give their spin and i just
wanted to ask the question who the heck
is this guy
uh what makes him tick
and how is it that he was able to amass
so much power okay so that's where i
really want to work today so
i'm my agenda if we have time i'll try
to get through
some or all of this up my agenda is
really to think about okay about him how
did he become laid a call
second
i want to think about him as a tiger in
the south um which i'll get to third the
architect of the organization the
essential organization of the communist
party and in conclusion um i want to
talk about if again if i have some time
i want to talk about how paul was able
to shape deut renovation okay
so this this image is an amazing image
this i'll i'll get to it in a moment
we'll come back to it but this is a
remarkable image anyway the first
section becoming later talk i want to
think about his early years who was he
where did he come from
so later tal happened to be born in 1911
in numbing province in the north
into a
uh into a what we might term a
middle-class numbing family
now many of
many official documents would call him
uh would say that he came from a peasant
family he did not
his family could trace their heritage
back to hanoi
um they were known i'll just put his
name up here for all of you see it's
kind of relevant fandenkai was his
actual name his birth name
fandenkai was born in 1911 as he said in
nambe uh his grandfather was
a failed uh mandarin he had passed
two exams and then failed ultimately i
think
one of the city exams this would have
been in the uh in the late
late
1800s he returned he became a medicinal
uh
an herbal medicinal doctor
uh pharmacist
and he became
when
fundenkai was born in 1911
10 years later he became pandenkai's uh
teacher uh he taught for taught him for
about two or three years until
he passed away now the thing that makes
this so interesting
is that when founding kai was born in
1911 it means that by the 1920s he's a
he's a team
um not much is really happening when
he's in his very early years but his
teen years are extremely traumatic both
his grandfather and his father died
within a span of five years between 1923
and then 1928.
uh
these two men were
clearly up until that point the two most
important figures in his life
and their death really struck him
what makes this all the more important
is as these two deaths occur
later tall is living in namdae which at
this time many of you may know um
at this time
in
in vietnam in indochina there is a lot
of there's a lot of seething feeling
against the colonial regime
there are uprisings and rebellions
including at this place associated with
india
the uh
the uh
this was
uh
one of the cotton factories one of the
the clothing factories in uh namding
in which uh later tah had gone to work
now by the time 1928 comes around
later call has apparently according to
official sources
has become a member
of the uh
excuse me he's become a member of the um
the youth league the revolutionary youth
league in vietnam and a couple years
later in 1930 he allegedly
again these are official sources but he
allegedly has become
a founding member of the indo-chinese
communist party again
we don't have other sources to back this
up this is according to official
backgrounds um but nonetheless
he's involved
he's clearly watching and and
very heavily influenced by two of these
two things number one the death of these
very important men in his life and the
other thing are the rebellions that are
occurring across indochina this is also
a time where there are
uh the uh
the death of fanchuchin
um and also the arrest of fanboy
two great uh
great heroes of uh vietnamese
nationalism in um of of that period
um and all of this we can imagine would
have had a profound effect on paul
so
what i kind of got to thinking was okay
so this had this profound effect but so
what
well as it turns out in 1930
later paul happened to be at this site
and it was uh on the
eve
excuse me the eve
of the 13th anniversary of the
russian
revolution um he's at this site
along with some other friends
and there is an explosion
uh in the roundup that followed so this
was around uh november 7th of 19 1930.
during the roundup later call was among
the
54 men
i believe all men who were rounded up as
suspects in the bombing and he was he
was confirmed at this point to be
himself a communist
uh his
his family home was raided
they discovered a great deal of
paraphernalia uh that was marxist um uh
and he was arrested
the arrest
and the reason i i showed you this image
earlier
this image is so evocative um i love
this picture
when he was arrested in 1930 this this
boy was 19 years old and i've always i
first saw this image when i went to
kondaow island
oh i don't remember when it was a long
time ago at any rate
this image is so evocative this is a
night
a 19 year old boy
um and i love just looking at his eyes
his face
um
i would ask everyone to kind of just
peer into those eyes there's
you get a sense there's it looks like
maybe some fear
uncertainty about the future uncertainty
about what who knows
uh but this it's a really
it's a really moving image uh and again
this is just a 19 year old boy
and i think the
first time i kind of
thought more about this image kind of
got me to thinking about later paul as
more than just this
one-dimensional figure opposed to people
like you know standing in in paris next
to
uh next to henry kissinger
but more just thinking about him and
you know whatever i think of his
politics whatever he did but thinking
about him as a as a human being
and again this is a young man who's just
a teenager a late teen but nonetheless a
teenager
so moving forward he is going to be
spending uh the next five to six years
on corndale islands
kondaow island many of you will know was
a prison island a very famous
famous french prison island
and he spent five to six years there he
was released in 1936
and he returned to namding
this was during the popular front they
they released many uh
many vietnamese
political prisoners
and he returned to namding and
what makes this an interesting time in
his life is he opens a book shop there
uh now the bookshop was a front uh again
for communist paraphernalia and also to
organize the uh the opera the apparatus
of the communist party in the region
um and during this time he became very
acquainted with uh i am many of you may
know the author
uh
is most famous for writing a book called
look uh at any rate book
was
was um
actually
the
the kind of impetus the inspiration for
this this story
came in uh later todd's uh bookstore
uh lady paul was uh working this
bookstore and uh when come on came uh
into the bookstore one day and they
started to chat as it turns out
later paul and when come on were very
familiar with each other because uh one
of later todd's
close prison mates on guangdow island
was the younger brother of when juan
at any rate
they became very acquainted and this
became a very important moment for both
men
this was an opportunity for later paul
to
uh
to
impress upon uh
impress upon when one the importance of
class and uh the importance of
recognizing
uh the the international revolution and
it really um it
really inspired women
uh three years afterwards and i want to
move forward guys three years afterwards
uh later paul was arrested again
and he was to move
this time he was to spend
the next three or four years in prison
among them was uh huala many of you will
know that place and then up in sungla
which is up in the mountains in
northwestern vietnam
he
while he was there um he uh
he was
he was the he became kind of the um how
we might describe him the chief of
party prison operations
so he was the head of the communist cell
within the prison
which led to a great deal of
interaction with many people of many
different backgrounds
um and through this interaction i think
that one of the keys that i see in this
prison time
uh and i just wanna i wanna leave it at
this because we do need to move forward
i think one of the
the things that we kind of take away
from the prison experience number one it
establishes his chops i think all of you
many of you will be familiar with peter
cinnamon's work in which peter zinniman
highlights in how important the prison
experience was to communist
revolutionaries establishing their chops
as revolutionaries and then also the the
education that they would receive the
communist education they received this
was indeed a form of schooling
the second thing that we see here
is that
later tall
demonstrates
a real
capacity for organization as i said he
becomes in his particularly in his
second stint in prison he becomes the
chief organizer within the prison walls
in fact he he allegedly organizes a
great prison break from the sun lab
prison he himself does not escape but
dozens of others do
and it was i actually i think i have the
book right here um
if any of you are interested this book
just came out last year i think many of
you can see this
it's just the chibo yeah
the uh
the
the sun lab prison cell uh communist
cell um it's a history of the the prison
um and the communist
party within it
but it demonstrates a man who is who is
a very capable organizer which i am
going to show you in this next section
again i know we don't have that much
time and i don't want to spend too much
too much more time on this this is where
we get to the to the to the meat
so
when
when later hall is released from prison
in 1944 1945
he's actually
remarkably enough despite the fact that
party histories tend to not discuss this
very much he has actually grown to quite
a significant figure within the
communist party in fact at the time of
the second
uh the first indochina war in 1945 1946
laid utah has become
uh
one of the closest advisers of ho chi
minh
in in in the north in fact let me see if
i have the yes here this is an image in
1947
of uh
of uh
on the left hand side ho chi minh
obviously in the middle long wind zap is
sitting right next to uh
right next to ho chi minh and bahat
between ho chi minh and bangla
in fact i love this picture because it
almost looks like uh
um ho chi minh chung ching and bong and
zap had set up this photograph they were
gonna sit together and then later kind
of rushed over to hey let me in guys
come on let me in let me in
um
and
so these were actually three of uh ho
chi minh's closest advisors at the
beginning of the first indochina war
uh this is something actually written
about by vuki in one of his uh memories
uh uh of the first indochina war writing
about uh later talk he describes how
later paul was in fact uh at this point
already
the chief organizer
of the s the civil apparatus of the
communist party versus vongwin's app who
would have been on the military side and
chung jing who is the the chief
ideologue
but later tall was already um of immense
importance to the actual organization
of the party system however
according to the memoirs that that exist
uh jung jing and later tall did not get
along
um and they often were found to be at
one another at odds with each other
and by 1947
48 um
the two men
uh jung jing and later paul were kind of
described
as
two tigers
hike on hole they were described as two
tigers uh two tigers ready to pounce on
one another
and it was decided that
that
they were going to have to be separated
for the sake of the party
and laid out hall according to several
memoirs had become a um
a man with a certain uh
the description by people like
is a man who had a lust for power
uh in fact there is a comment in both
and
books
that
allegedly uh later paul would claim to
some of his subordinates that that he
was the party
um he he would say uh
i am the party the party is me
now of course these are memoirs
and they are unofficial and we have no
other um
we have no other evidence for this other
than what people recall and obviously we
know that memory is fickle uh but it is
interesting nonetheless whatever the
situation whatever that was going on
nonetheless in 1948
uh later paul is ordered to head south
to
help with the um
to buttress and support the
southern the regional uh party apparatus
in the south in the mekong delta
now
as best as we can tell later paul was
furious about having to leave the north
and having to leave the center of the
action to leave the uh
to leave you know where
where much of the first indochina war
was occurring and where the seat of
power for the communist party at this
stage still was
however
this is a really important moment in
later paul's life um and also in the
life of the party
uh for
for several reasons but key here
is that despite the fact that later paul
might have been upset about being kicked
southward
about perhaps he might have seen this as
a demotion which it probably was by
being sent southward and away from the
central apparatus
nonetheless this turned out to be a
remarkable boom to him
uh because of this movements uh because
of this move south a couple of things
would happen number one
uh he would get to work with leiswon who
i'll talk about in a second
uh
uh who would become later on the general
secretary of the communist party for
over 26 years
uh and they would work very closely with
for for decades
the second thing was because he went
southward in 1948 and he would stay
there until 1955 he became insulated
from the disastrous land reform that
occurred in 1953
began in 1953 and it would run until
1956 because
later paul went southward in 1950
in 1948
he was going to have the opportunity
to avoid all of these
all of the stench and stain
of the um
of uh of of land reform so when he
arrived south
um i know today
some of you have
maybe read some of these books that have
come out in recent years about uh the
relationship between liaison and later
talk
uh when he arrives in 1948 there's a
meeting allegedly there's a meeting
between later paul and leisuan
a couple of scholars have discussed this
at any rate
uh according to to to lord later later
paul arrives in the south
and he meets liaison for the very first
time
liaison is this kind of a dour figure he
doesn't smile a lot
uh at any rate when later later paul
meets him for the first time the thought
was the belief was that later was going
to take over the party apparatus in the
south
um because that's what he was said to do
however upon meeting liaison
according to these descriptions there
have been several writers who've
mentioned them and i could discuss it
that length later
but upon meeting leswa
later paul is so
taken
by the personality of leisure he decides
that it's best that if he steps back
and becomes uh
becomes lays one's subordinate
now this description um is it's an
interesting one
but it's really not based in in fact uh
in fact
there's no possibility that liaison and
later talk were not familiar with each
other uh both of them were high-ranking
party officials already number one
number two
uh both had been in prison on guangdow
island now whether or not they were in
the same cell block perhaps they had
they had not met each other but they
were certainly familiar with each other
and the notion that lei leyton would not
have known
is is is really doubtful uh that's
number one
but the next part the second part to
this is
why might he have
given away power to lays one why might
have he decided to become a subordinate
well i would argue this and i and i
believe this to have been the case
number one based on what uh what i read
of the the documents that do exist and
granted i i need to admit here that i
have not had an opportunity to look at
his personal files in the archives i've
not been given permission something i
would really like to do um
but what i
what i surmise happens is this he
arrives in the south
lays liaison indeed is in charge of the
regional apparatus there
but later tall
was a was a smart man
and he realized several things number
one
he didn't have a foothold he didn't have
a place in the south yet uh and for him
to take over uh the the southern
regional apparatus would have caused a
great deal of trouble uh with uh
the local uh party apparatus there
that's number one number two uh
later top was um
as i said a really great organizer and i
believe what he thought was it would be
better to work from
behind the throne rather than seated in
it
and i think that's what he did
so
what i mean by this he arrives in the
south he takes over the organizing uh
organizing of the party he leaves the
the leading of the party to liaison in
the south
in so doing
as the organizer and i and i should
explain this
several of the the
several of the key
uh aspects of organization within the
party at this point is this
number one he's in charge of health care
number two as i said before he's in
charge of moving uh
uh moving party members around within um
within the apparatus
but
but number three another thing that he
becomes in charge of
is relationships
so
marriage relationships became one of his
key uh
one of his key jobs in the south
so one of the first people that he
arranges a marriage for happens to be
liaison
uh in 1949 liaison uh meets a a woman by
the name of matt
uh
and
uh he is smitten with her and he
actually mentions the later call that oh
my goodness you know i i i've met this
woman
uh
and i think i would like to to marry her
now liaison already had a wife north put
that aside he decides he wants to to
marry a second wife
um and it's laid at all who arranges
this marriage
now uh in party history in in
in vietnam we don't really have much
research
done yet on this
but it's interesting in chinese studies
there has been work done on
how the communist party of china
used marriage as a tool
to
bind party members
allegiances to the party because
obviously as many of you may know this
idea of arranged marriages the person
who arranges a marriage
is owed a debt of gratitude from the
people who who are married
um and this is the case here uh le lais
one's marriage is indeed a arranged by
late later call um and it
yes it um yes leisuan was the
uh superior
but
lay
later paul becomes the
uh how shall i say
he becomes
the uh
the debt he's the person that lays one
owes a great debt to
and immediately
upon
this marriage and upon taking his place
as a subordinate we immediately realize
this the the evidence in the archives
shows this
is that
uh lays one becomes
uh almost completely
trusting
of later call so at one point i i think
i have some notes here that i'd love to
have put yes um give me just a moment
yes um indeed uh
in
1950
a uh a party secretary from jalan comes
to leisure
and he complains he says
since paul has come south
comrades from all over come to speak
with me
i no longer see anyone talking to you
so les one was
was completely surprised
by this
and he says to
uh this this party secretary uh this
provincial secretary
what are you talking about that's
nonsense comrades lining up to meet with
paul is a good thing it indicates they
trust the central committee
what are you trying to imply by selling
the name of tom
so
it's remarkable
the way it
what this actually shows it shows that
paul has ingratiated himself to lay down
number one and number two it shows
actually
later cause recognition of how power
works
about how he can actually by standing
a rung below
by not being
the
the absolute leader but by being a
lieutenant he can actually control the
flow of information which is what i
argue he does subsequently at when he
becomes the chief of uh the central
organization committee a central
organization commission beginning in
1955 56
i think this is a really important
moment for
not just
it wasn't you know for me as i was
reading this i realized my goodness
um
the way power is working here we you
know we often think top down
but the way it's working here is it
flows downward but then upward and the
amount of information that is flowing to
uh to lays one in this case
is determined by later paul
and we would see this moving forward
um i don't want mrs paul in lays one
around 1950 in fact this is the entire
leadership of the southern uh regional
apparatus you see uh liaison is on the
far left
uh later paul is standing next to the
the man in the middle there in the in
the white is
later be prime minister uh and later
talk there are right next to him on the
on the right uh these are all figures
the the main members of the southern
apparatus
um but i would like to move us forward
anoth another image of these men
but what i want to move over uh to uh is
the architect uh later paul is an
architect of uh
of
of organization in in in the drv the
democratic republic of vietnam in the
north so his building of this
organization
so
uh later call
spends these
uh what is it uh six seven years in the
south from 48 to about 1955
and he returns north after the geneva
accords and of course as i mentioned to
you his sojourn in the south
would prevent would protect him from
being involved with this horrible
horrible
land reform project uh that was
was clearly
many of you may know uh turned out to be
uh disastrous for the communist party
and it led to ho chi minh
and vong wenzap having to apologize
subsequently after 1956 1957
but
later call he returns in 1955
um and
several of the people who've been
involved in land reform are demoted
one of those who's demoted is the man
who is a man who was standing in as the
chief of the central organization
commission upon his return to the north
later is handed that position
now
the job of the central organization
commission is is fascinating as i
mentioned to you he was a in charge of
the nomenclature the nomenclature is
this list of names it's basically all
the communist party members
but later tall really shaped this uh
nomenclature and the central
organization commission in his own image
there's been quite a bit of research
done on other uh central organization
commissions as nomenclature
in other countries in other communist
countries very little done in vietnam
but i love this image here uh you'll
notice later tall is standing in the
front and all of these people are
members of the central organization
commission they were actually this was
upon later paul's return
from paris and i think this was around
march of 1973 maybe uh he had traveled
on to the soviet union after that if i
recall correctly anyway he's returned i
love this image because it shows
he's such a homely guy he's here with
his family which are all these members
of the central organization commission
this doesn't look like an office that
should scare us this looks like an
office they look like people
you might like to have a cup of tea with
some coffee with there are young
children in the front row there's a baby
being held in the third row there
this looks like a very familial oriented
organization well
one of the great things about this image
it also uh is indicative of the way
later paul was able to build loyalty of
people so yes he returns north and yes
he he
um he ascends to uh leadership of the
central organization commission
but in so doing
um
he is charged with by 1956-57
he is charged with the with dealing with
the rectification of errors uh the
rectification of errors follows the land
reform
and it's
involves
uh returning many of the
many communist party members who had
been wronged during the land reform
who are
renovated they are brought back
and we're talking thousands upon
thousands of communist party members
well it's later paul
who is charged with this um and one
example of this there's a great story
many of you may be familiar with the
very first person murdered during the
land reform her name was
she was this great um this wondrous
figure i know guys give me just a couple
of moments and i'll and i'll close out
i have so much stuff and i apologize to
all of you at any rate um he uh he's the
one who uh who
saves
uh her two sons uh one son was uh
was was injured during the first
indochina war and the whole family was
left with this big black mark on their
their background because of um
because their mother
nam
had been
labeled a great landlord
this was a horrible label to hold
and her and the two young men who were
actually soldiers her sons
uh were suffered mightily because of it
upon his return
he was the one who who went to them and
made sure that they were taken care of
and that the family was renovated and
restored
when vietnam had actually been a great
help to the revolution she had housed ho
chi minh and several other
significant figures of the party during
the first indochina war
only to be
called a landlord later on and as i said
the first person murdered during the
land reform
uh the point of me telling this story
is
it's laid a call who returns north after
or
towards the end of land reform
and is the person who is renovating so
many of these figures who had suffered
greatly because of land reform and
returns them to their place in the party
these people going forward
have
immense loyalty and immense feeling
toward him so what i'd like to highlight
right here
um and i know i need to to move forward
just give me a moment guys what i'd like
to highlight here with respect to
marriage later paul
recognized the power that he could he
could garner over people by arranging
marriages which he did many of including
liaison in fact
this is a wonderful story in fact what's
remarkable he actually got a very
derisive name
uh later taught it uh the name was
einsau brother six tuba
i don't know how many of you are
familiar with the tale of gil
but uh in it the bravo owner uh her name
is tuba
and
so laid at all became known as
brother six uh the brothel owner the
reason they named him this
was because he
was known for arranging marriages and
trysts
between women of the south
and most all of the uh northern um uh
communist party leadership
um
at any rate this was a very derisive uh
nickname but nonetheless it suggests the
power that he wielded over uh the
communist party and i think again we
know very little about the
kind of
the personal relationships that men and
women of the party had during this
period
this is what we see here is kind of
giving us a window on to that
and as i said this is a way of wielding
a great deal of power and obviously
another way in this way
uh
you know this ability to restore
families
to
um to some some form of normalcy and
return them giving them a position
within the party within the government
uh obviously it would lend itself to
giving uh
uh later tall a great deal of
of support from all these thousands
thousands of people
at any rate um
he establishes he builds a central
organization commission and i just
wanted to close with this
he is able to build loyalty throughout
the party by this time the central
organization commission by 1960 is now
in charge of literally millions of
over a million people
moving people around within the party
uh
which is significant
he's the person who decides where where
you go as the head of this organization
he decides where you go
therefore people are beholden to him
not the party
he became the
the kind of firewall for information and
later on um as this is an image of him
in 1960 and later on at the sixth
by the sixth party congress this is 1986
this is the deui mai congress um
ledot has
has gained so much power
uh but people have within the party
leisuan
uh
uh long winds up have come to realize
the kind of figure that laid out is or
at least they've come to believe this to
to be what he is which is a
machiavellian figure this idea of
vietnam's machiavelli comes from this
period by the sixth party congress later
paul is seen as a figure who has only
one thing in mind which is to move
pieces around i i'm sorry i wish i had
more time i i would love to talk more
about the sixth party congress
maybe i can save it for q a right now
but i know i'm already way past time i
forgive me eric i apologize for talking
so much
i've left so much on the table all of
you please forgive me
jason um no need to apologize um this
gives me the opportunity to invite you
back um oh no this has been
i've been enraptured from the very
moment you started telling this story
it's really quite full of information
um
well too much i'm afraid i'm too much
i'm afraid i apologize to all of you
we'll bring you back um for i think
maybe we can do another talk from the
sixth party congress on it'll be i would
love to
yeah i would love to
what i'd like to do now is open it up to
q a and if there's anyone who has to
leave at the hour or pretty soon feel
free to raise your hand first so i'll
i'll withhold my own questions for a
moment um i want to make sure anyone who
has an immediate question gets to go
first so just re use the um the the
reaction feature the raise hand function
on zoom
and i'll call on you in order
koi
sorry i see a note from
koi absolutely please feel free to reach
out to me and i'm i am available in
vietnam
coy um while you're here uh would you
like to ask a question
uh thank you professor picard this is
koi uh
it's a it's this uh i was wondering how
um
accessible the archives is for for uh
these figures and any other um
figures is there is there some
censorship going or uh
i think that's a probably a broader
question so uh
please uh please feel free to defer that
what a great question thank you coy
that's great that's a good start up so i
got actually very lucky and i probably
should have introduced this at the
beginning of what as well i have a
student who as it turns out her family
is uh
very closely related to later call
their their last name is fine it used to
be funding
the family actually changed it uh due to
uh
due to later talk um it became a
at some point in the late 70s early 80s
it became
at least for this part of the family had
become a badge of shame at any rate i
had met with
several members of the family they were
actually i guess because she is a
student of mine they were very
forthcoming in sharing uh material with
me however your question koi about the
archives itself it is really hard to get
information in the archives the uh
personal information is almost
impossible um it requires uh it requires
um
uh um
a permission from the family which i
have not received not not the family
that i know but the uh direct relatives
uh meaning his children uh which i have
not gotten in fact i tried to meet with
his daughter that didn't go anywhere
um
it's clear they're very sensitive about
that so no it's very hard but with that
said
memoirs exist uh there's obviously a
great deal of official history
um and then actually later thought
himself has left behind a h
actually a treasure trove he he himself
did a great deal of writing he was a
poet left behind a great deal of poetry
and you can actually use many newspapers
dating all the way back to the 1930s and
40s where he appears
so
there is there is a an avenue for for
gleaning um quite a bit of information
about him but no
much of the archives are still
you know still off limits but with that
said
um i i have i actually have a invitation
next week to go visit the archives here
in in in hanoi uh which i'm really
looking forward to and i've been told
that i'll be able to look at um uh
some documents that may be relevant to
my topic
jason um while people are thinking of
questions um yeah i have several but i
want to start with one um
you mentioned
you you sort of end with him becoming a
machiavelli figure um and obviously you
had more to say
but yes
what we got up until this point is
actually a pretty congenial figure um
you know using arranged marriages a
pretty happy um organizational life with
with that um office photo that you
showed towards the end and those kinds
of things right um in fact many of the
pictures too they're quite striking
especially the one in the south where
where they're standing on the bridge
there
like the kind of joyousness of the
smiles that they have and those kinds of
things right and so i'm curious um
how do you reconcile that side with the
ruthless and what are some of the if you
were to say
here's the ruthless side what would be
the example or two examples that really
are undeniable and how do you reconcile
that with that other side
well number one so when i first came to
this you know i i want to admit that's a
great question eric in fact you know
this is one of the things i struggle
with when i came to it i had already
determined he was a machiavellian figure
i was you know that's what i knew
but as i started to do this project i
became more and more i sympathetic i
don't want to say that i certainly don't
agree with a lot of things he did
um he clearly could be uh um
he
clearly could be ruthless but i want to
take you back to that first picture i
showed
the first image of him in prison
um
uh
you know
it is a really telling photograph this
is a 19 year old who's clearly just been
beaten he's as i said you see some fear
some uncertainty
uh not having ever
lived through anything like that through
what he experienced i can't possibly you
know i can
i can certainly
say
you know things that he did were wrong
uh evil whatever but
when you look at those eyes when you
think about what he endured prison
uh two wars
uh
you know i think
i have to admit the more and more i read
the less and less i i'm more inclined to
put a question mark next to machiavelli
or machiavellian
uh because
part of me thinks it's not that much
different than
most other most other figures within the
party at this time
this was like number one life or death
second thing what we know about
communism
is
it doesn't share power
it's
it um and i think some of these
i mentioned he
allegedly said something like i am the
party the party is is me um and i think
we need to look at when that came up if
you if you wouldn't mind can i show you
in another image
sure okay um and again
uh i'm gonna just go to this one so
there's this image this is at towards
the end of their lives this is les one
on the right in the middle of jung jing
and fanbando
um
great figures uh like remarkable figures
i i shouldn't say great but remarkable
figures um and this is at the end of
their lives met for many years these
three men had at times been at odds with
each other hated each other
or maybe maybe hates not the right word
but certainly
had tremendous disagreements
um and
were on opposite
sides of the
of the kind of spectrum as it were in
during the war
but towards the end of their lives they
clearly you know you can see it in this
image they clearly have a real
admiration for one another this
photograph was taken in 1985
but that's this is the official
photograph
that often you see in you know books and
in newspapers but that's not the actual
original photograph this was
that's the original photograph
it's these three men and in the back
it's laid it tall
latex i love this photograph
and because later todd was often taken
out of this image i love this photograph
it tells us so much i think for so many
especially in the 1970s and 80s to your
questionnaire especially in the 1970s
and 80s
a lot of these a lot of these figures
the party itself was looking for
scapegoats
um and one of those would ultimately
become later tall
now
um there is a lot of salacious material
about what later paul did um some of it
probably was true for instance his role
in the um
many of you may be familiar but his role
in the anti-party affair of the the
1960s he is kind of seen as the man who
uh led the charge on behalf of liaison
because liaison was was was privy to
this as well but because of later cause
uh um connection
uh to the uh organization commission and
therefore his connection to uh internal
affairs or and also the public security
apparatus
he is regarded as the man who really
organized uh the anti-party affair
that's number one and number two uh many
of you have may have already heard this
story before again i want to be very
clear here
i don't have any evidence for this but
one of the stories is is that uh
ley de paul actually had ho chi minh's
wife his alleged wife murdered in 1957.
again these are salacious stories i do
not know if that's true or not i want to
be very clear here all right but these
are the kinds of stories that come up so
when i so i think to your point eric
there are a host of stories i could tell
you
whether or not they're true
i don't know
um and the more i hear about
the more i'm learning about later call
and again i'm really early into this the
more i learn about him the more
i become sympathetic about what he was
doing he was clearly trying to organize
the party uh and i see there's plenty of
things i would disagree with what he did
he probably he could be ruthless um he
definitely destroyed some people's lives
um i i do see that
but i am careful to uh to
i want to be very careful about how we
present this and i think it's important
you know
i've just recently been reading stephen
cotkins uh
biography of uh of stalin and even there
i mean he
demonstrates a certain
sensitivity uh i don't know if sympathy
is a right word but certainly a certain
sensitivity toward
towards stalin and as brutal and
horrible as he was
um
i don't know if that helped eric if you
want if you want to go further another
question from david but i was just
thinking as you were talking that i mean
obviously you don't want to go down the
path where everything's centered around
american-centric narratives but
it seems to me that some of that
double-sidedness
uh also appears with henry kissinger so
it might be interesting to read some
biographies of him too for comparative
stuff but let me make sure that david
can ask his question
yeah absolutely go for it david go ahead
david yes
thank you jason picard that was
wonderful that was just a
a very intriguing
set of uh stories um i want to just ask
you a little bit about my new interest
in ho chi minh i wondered yes i wondered
if you could um
recommend
a biography of him in english
and let me know if there's other books
that have not been translated that are
better
well you know
wow well first of all this isn't a
biography i'm going to make a plug for
one of my
my classmates at the university of
california berkeley
it's not a biography but nonetheless
alec holcomb's new book that just came
out uh
late last year this year
is is wonderful and he does speak to ho
chi minh quite a bit
and alec is just a brilliant scholar so
i would first recommend that
uh the next thing
you know it's funny recently i'm trying
to think of anything really new and
exciting that's come out in in english
about ho chi minh i mean still the go-to
book i think is uh
unfortunately 20 years later uh william
dwyker's book uh ho chi minh life that's
still the one book that people go to
that covers
literally covers his life
um
another
so recently i'm actually working on the
translation
i'm excited i'm really excited because
i've been in talks with verso about the
translation
but uh uh there's a book called the
winning side it's by a a journalist here
in vietnam
it's not a specifically about ho chi
minh but it's about the communist party
it's a history of the communist party
since 1975 but it does much more than
just post war history
this covers the party since its
inception and it it has all of these
figures in it ho chi minh lady paw leis
and it's a brilliant weaving together of
basically
an entire history of the party since
uh since 1930 um it's truly remarkable
he covers the end of the
you know to eric's point
not coming from a u.s perspective it
starts with the collapse of the south
from a nor from a a communist
perspective the arrival of the
communists in the south and it moves
from there into things like uh
re-education
uh the um the beau people
cambodia
uh doi mai
then it talks about the constitution i
mean there's a chapter on the
constitution that goes from 1946 all the
way up to 2000 uh all the way up to the
present or up to 2011. uh there's
another chapter on literature in vietnam
the impact of uh
on literature but he toggles all the way
back in that chapter he toggles all the
way back to the 1950s
so it's it's brilliant the way um he is
able to bring in so many sources so many
vietnamese sources
um from literature to interviews with
some of the most important figures in
the government to archives to newspapers
um to also to even like uh folk folk
tales that are you know these like uh
post 1975
folk sayings folk tales folk stories
um it's brilliant it's really brilliant
so anyway i would i would urge you hang
in there in another year
i i think we might have uh we might have
this but
we might have this book in process in in
uh in translation um
yes
that's right
yes he did uh peter did translate that i
would i would urge you yes
to eric arms that's right um i would
urge you to read peter's uh review um
it's it's a
of the book uh the winning side it's
called
david
and it's not yet out in english
no it's not but you can go online you
can actually read about it there's quite
a bit written about it in english
great thank you
yes absolutely
that's a david that's a really important
question you know why
yeah biography man there's just not
enough on for vietnam it's sad
sad
sorry
eric did you have another question
yeah i haven't i have another question
um so
i was really interested in this period
in the south
and you said that it ended in 55
um and then that it made me think about
uh
your other work which you you're working
on the book manuscript
which is about 54.55 and then that led
me to think of
a question i'd never thought to ask
before but
these kind of party leaders who went to
the south like around the period
right before
um there's going to be this big
migration south
did they overlap and did they have like
a plan for what to do with all these
catholics coming down and how to like
how to manipulate that whole situation
i'm just curious like he was there sort
of when the first migrants must have
been coming and so i'm wondering if you
learned anything about that connection
to think of it not specifically with
relationship to later paul but it's
clear that the you know i have
i have like
60 different memoirs uh relating to
alleged
spies who went south in
1954-55 with those migrants to stir up
trouble um you mentioned one of my
papers
uh in which i talk about um actually may
not have mentioned but there's i wrote a
paper
that starts with the um
the great uh
uh
the great um
scare of 1955 in march of 1955
uh there's a rumor that's spreading all
over saigon in which uh
um
in which allegedly northern migrants are
are abducting young children to harvest
their
bodies for meat that they're going to
put in the fall sorry forgive me for
everyone for
giving such a description but this was
in and this was quite serious it was in
all of the newspapers in saigon and
because of it um
in fact at that point note exam and the
mayor of saigon had to come out and
allay people's fears you know this
wasn't true uh there's no evidence for
this i have seen no evidence for this
but this was clearly um
a roost that was cooked up by
by
communists but as i argue
by communist spies but as i argue
there was clearly something in the minds
of southerners that would allow them to
believe that so that's another that's a
question for another day but there were
i have a host of these memoirs of spies
who come south in 54-55
and
they are
certainly causing trouble one other
story and this is connected to later
call later tall returns north
um
in early 1954 on a polish ship the
kolinsky i believe it's called
interestingly enough uh
a couple weeks after he arrives in the
north that ship
returns south
uh it's one of the few uh non-french and
american ships to to carry passengers
south
it returned south the manifest claims
that it had it was supposed to have 3
000 people aboard about 3 000 people
aboard however it arrives with almost 3
500 people aboard because of that
the zm government sent all these people
to fukuoka and had them in detention for
several months
clearly this was something that was
drummed up by the communists in the
north they did this they they knew
what was going to happen
uh they they um they did this for a
purpose and obviously as i said this was
a polish ship
uh
so there
there may have been some involvement of
uh
uh
international communism as well in that
but beyond that i i can't say it's a
really good question it's definitely one
to
to to look at
um you know there's 300 days of free
passage that you're referring to as well
it's a it's a fascinating tale it's a
fascinating story